[موسيقى]
مازلنا مشاهدينا مع هذه الصور الحيه
والمباشره بالصوت والصوره من الخرطوم
تحديدا من محيط القياده العامه للجيش
السوداني ايضا في الاخبار العاجله التي
تاتينا الان انباء عن تبادل اطلاق النار
بين الجيش والدعم السريع في محيط مبنى
الاذاعه والتلفزيون ايضا اذا تصاعد هذه
الاشتباكات بعد مده هدنه هشه لم تصمت ساعه
واحده
وطبعا هذه الاشتباكات تتركز في محيط
القياده العامه للجيش السوداني وانباء
ايضا عن تبادل لاطلاق النار واشتباكات في
محيط مبنى الاذاعه والتلفزيون وانتم ما
زلتم مشاهدينا مع هذه الصور المباشره التي
نرى فيها ارتفاع اعمده الدخان من محيط
القياده العامه للجيش السوداني لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنس وا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات